ich finde dieses buch ist total
kraftausdrücken hat irgendwie ein
bisschen was von einer anmache und du
lässt dich von tom kummer an thomas
nicht persönlich werden
ich habe ein buch mitgebracht
ausnahmsweise morgen der hunger von
schlechten eltern ich war wahnsinnig
positiv überrascht von diesem buch wenn
man sich überlegt man schreibt über den
tod seiner eigenen frau und mann
schreibt darüber wie man mit den zwei
kindern weiterleben muss dann denkt man
sich europäisch verdacht kitschverdacht
ich finde er hat es wirklich sehr gut
umgesetzt das ist so ein sound in moll
ist es stilistisch eigentlich er
journalistisch geschrieben und das hat
mich reingeflogen in diese trauer das
spielt ja vor allem nachts und so ist
auch der sound das ist wirklich
überdeckt von dunkelheit
ich finde das von der idee vom plot von
der konstruktion her großartig und dann
finde ich sprachlich kommt er nicht mit
es ist wie eine obsession von trauer die
da verhandelt wird
plötzlich will er von seiner frau
vorüber gezogen werden in die todes welt
es hat dann auch noch so magische
elemente von afrikanischen philosophien
dass man wie geht man mit dem tod um bei
uns das finde ich alles relativ plakativ
auch so dieses motiv da konnte ich zwei
drei mal vor damit es auch ja nicht
übersehen so wenn man seine toten nicht
begräbt hat man ein problem und so das
finde ich alles ist ein bisschen wie
wenn ich hier von der figur rede ist das
für mich eine fiktive figur oder sie tom
kummer und diese fiktive figur hat ja im
buch auch was über griffiges dem eigenen
sohn den er als der sohn irgendwie die
mutter also die verlorene frau zulächelt
hieraus zuströmen scheint gibt es da so
sehen die so vorsichtig ausgedrückt auf
der kippe sind und ich finde eben das
buch hat in seiner gesamten haltung
etwas total über griffiges deswegen
finde es auch interessant dass du sagst
es ist eine besessenheit mit der eigenen
trauer war für mich sagt dieses buch
komm mal her zu mir ich erzählte ihr von
meiner faszinierenden art und weise
trauer zu erleben ich finde dieses buch
hat ganz viele stellen die ziemlich
platt sind zum beispiel diese stelle ist
glaube ich das gelbe dingen wäre liebe
endlos würde sie uns nicht so berühren
wie sie es tut das ist die vergänglich
das ganze in jedem schlagertexte
das ist jetzt keine besonderes profil
der erkenntnis in einem buch über trauer
kann nicht egozentrik im zentrum stehen
denn trauer ist dass ausgerechnet du
dich an der egozentrik an der ich stelle
mich grundsätzlich habe ja auch kein
buch über trauer zum glück habe ich
keinen anlass dazu aber ich finde es ist
eine fixierung auf das eigene schicksal
auf die eigene verlassenheit auf die
eigene verlorenheit und auf die r und
auf die eigene situation es ist doch in
sich total stimmig was erfahren wir
wirklich über diesen geliebten menschen
um den hier angeblich 1007 sieht noch
klein aber darum geht es nicht es geht
um das eigene gefühl der verlorenheit es
geht wirklich um diesen kleinen kosmos
wenn du ihn zurückgeworfen ist auf eine
trauer dann findest nur noch durch stadt
ich will gar nicht sagen dass das gefühl
der trauer nicht auch mit egozentrik zu
tun hat es geht dem autor vielleicht
doch mehr darum ich sag das jetzt
bewusst sehr vorsichtig die interessant
hat seine eigenen gefühle nein das nicht
unbedingt tatsächlichen verlust
auseinander zu finde ich gar nicht es
geht um die lehrstelle und die
lehrstelle wird nicht gefüllt er wird
hineingezogen in dieses vakuum ich vom
bildhafte ist dieses buch sehr
überzeugend ich sehe da eine stufe noch
dazwischen geschaltet und das ist dass
der autor wie immer versucht zu sagen
bitte hier komm mal her ich erzähle ja
von meiner wahnsinnig faszinierenden
trauer und ich habe da für bilder und
zustände gefunden die noch keiner je
genannt hat und wenn ich tatsächlich die
bilder finden würde die noch keiner je
gefunden hätte würde ich mich sogar
darauf einlassen aber für mich ist es
leider oft wirklich flach viel flacher
als die schweiz durch die er mit dem
auto fährt